pour hervé gaymard c'est une manière de
ne fâcher personne ni les agriculteurs
ni les apiculteurs et de ne pas
totalement tranché le régent soupçonnait
de tuer les abeilles est suffisamment
dangereux pour que le ministre décide en
interdire la commercialisation mais pas
suffisamment pour proscrire
l'utilisation des stocks déjà traités
l'avis de la commission d'étude de la
toxicité fait état de problèmes pour
l'environnement et pour la faune sauvage
ne fait pas à ce jour état de problèmes
pour la santé humaine ou l'utilisation
pourvu que les précautions d'utilisation
soit respectée dans ces conditions là il
nous a paru que pour les semis de
printemps
ceux qui étaient déjà distribués devait
pouvoir être utilisé en clair le régent
ne peut être vendu mais peut encore être
utilisé une victoire à la pyrrhus pour
les apiculteurs qui accusent ce produit
d'anéantir leurs ruchers c'est incomplet
nous espérions une interdiction totale
du régent à partir d'aujourd'hui et non
pas à partir de 2005 puisque c'est le
cas on étant donné que les agriculteurs
vont pouvoir l'utiliser pour les semis
2004 nous continuons le combat il n'est
pas question que nous baissions les bras
tant que nous n'aurons pas satisfaction
sur toute la ligne
une prise de position gouvernementale
précipitée par l'action de la justice ce
matin quelques jours a fait la société
basf c'est autour du cou bailleur
cropscience propriétaire du régent
d'être mise en examen pour mise en vente
d'un produit toxique pour l'homme et
l'animal
l'administration a toujours délivrer les
autorisations pour ce produit
l'administration nous les a communiqués
nous les avons reçus nous avons
considéré que dès lors que l'admiration
donner toute autorisation sur ce produit
il pouvait parfaitement être
commercialisé ce qui a été le cas les
mines
a également demandé aux agences
sanitaires de se pencher sur le gaucho
un autre insecticides
de nouvelles études censé départager les
experts dont les avis multiples n'ont
cessé d'être divergent sur la question